all right this is a level 45
candy crusher saga walkthrough tutorial
video
i was writing up the guide for this and
realized it's pretty tough level
um
it's an early chocolate level but it's
it's up there with some of the harder
ones
so i thought i would play through and um
you know the main thing in the beginning
is to clear out this middle space so i'm
going to go ahead and
start working on that
um you do want to set up combos
you know
as you go
but you also want to um
just work your way down at the same time
so like
the um like if you get a striped or
a raft or whatever it's okay to just
fire it off in the beginning
i move this one down so it'll make more
it'll have more damage
because it's going to make another one
and they're both going to explode
but as a general rule you know you can
you don't want to get too fancy in the
beginning because you want to clear out
the space
that's more important than um
coming up with some big combo
and even if you think about it like
you know color bomb isn't that valuable
by itself in the very beginning because
there's not a lot of room to um
put it to use so
kind of the combo that you want to get
is this one right here down at the
bottom it'll really plow through
all this licorice and stuff
and one of the things
that you need to do or you don't need
yeah you i think you need to is you need
to keep the
chocolate under control so every once in
a while you're going to make matches
that you know don't really lead to much
but at the same time
they're going to keep that from growing
so
we have this red piece
in the middle
and i really don't know i can get it out
of there
and i don't want to waste a bunch of
moves trying to do that so
i'm just going to go ahead and fire off
the stripes
so like earl like the combos that you
want kind of change as you go in the
beginning the um
stripes was wrapped or
a fish plus a horizontal stripe those
are good because we have these two you
know we have these long rows down here
that we're trying to get rid of
and then as you go
you
want to look for something bigger such
as a
you know color bomb plus a fish or a
color bomb plus a stripe or something
like that
because that's what's really going to
hit a lot of areas of the board
so here
you know the fish by itself isn't that
great i don't really see anything else i
can get together with it though and if i
match it and activate it here it'll at
least keep the
chocolate check
and that just you know gives me another
move where you know i got another chance
to make a special
so this is just a jumbled mess down here
i'm gonna go ahead and um
try to set this off and make a new one
that was actually a miss click i was
trying to uh
trying to make a fish up there and it
didn't match exactly what i wanted and
it chuckled and gave me a color bomb so
it's a
happy accident
anybody remembers bob ross
all right so
this color bomb stripe would be nice
we'll set that up
we don't have a lot of red on the board
we have 14 moves and
nothing
i'm gonna see if i can't
carefully i'm gonna see if i can't bring
some more
red down
i mean i don't mind making that one
because it will
you know hit the chocolate so i kept it
from changing i don't really see too
many other matches
except for this red one which that just
takes more right off the board
like i could get
um
i could get crazy and set these off
because i know they're going to get set
off
most likely remember the stripes come
out but
there's a good chance that this might
fall and
the stripe might get activated by itself
so
i really wish there was some right at
the top so i'm just going to make this
match and okay that's better than
nothing up there so let me go
go ahead and make that now
and um i mean i've been i've been
playing this sort of like all afternoon
on and off to to write the tips and
i really think that those are the only
ways you know making those bigger
matches is the only way you're ever
going to really beat it consistently
it's just the it's just
like i said i mean i've played a lot of
harder what i would consider to be
harder chocolate levels now but this
one's still top i mean it doesn't
you know there's no like way that you
could say you're going to beat it every
single time
all right so i have this
i have this one um
wrapped here that'll kind of take out
this corner
only have nine moves left and um
this isn't going anywhere at the moment
so i'm gonna i'm gonna wait but now i'm
gonna do that soon
but what i wanna do is match this strike
and then i'm hoping that it's gonna go
straight up and hit one of the ones
and that's exactly what i wanted to
happen there
um
color bomb yes
this is one of those matches i was
talking about that you can make everyone
smile just to keep the chocolate from
spreading
oh
i really wanted to get that um
that wrapped candy with the collarbone
but that's all right
let me go ahead and set this off
now
okay
so this is
this is what we're gonna do i'm gonna
hit the orange it's gonna take out these
two pieces of chocolate then i have this
fish over here that i can activate and
that'll get the last one
you could do it the other way too i mean
you could match the red first and then
do this
but since we have three moves we'll go
for the extra style points
and now since there's only one piece of
chocolate the fish will definitely go
there
and there you go and like i said i think
you know the main thing
is you really just need to
keep your eyes peeled and set up on
those big combos um i'll have a list of
different ones that are effective
in the guide so you can see that and
i hope you found this helpful
it definitely is a tougher level
and
if you have any questions leave a
comment please like the video if you
found it helpful
and i'll see you soon